my name is Jim Crist I work for anaconda
and I'm here to talk to you about a
project called skåne so just quick poll
the audience here how many people use
Hadoop sometimes okay how many people
use Hadoop on a local cluster something
you might have is installed in your
enterprise for and how many people use
it on some kind of cloud deployment like
EMR okay wonderful
so I'm here talking about skåne it's a
deploy Python on your dupe cluster
easily so first let's define some terms
Hadoop clusters this is Hadoop is kind
of an overloaded term if you look at the
Hadoop project the actual Hadoop repo
it's full of things like MapReduce
there's yarn the resource manager
there's HDFS and then there's like
ancillary projects that you might also
install in your cluster so in this case
we're gonna say a group cluster is a
cluster of nodes managed by Apache yarn
has many different forms you might have
an enterprise distribution like Claudia
or her and works map are etc or you
might be using some form of cloud
deployment like EMR Google data proc or
maybe a custom installation all of these
are at their core running Apache are in
the manage jobs Apache yarn is yet
another resource negotiator that's what
it stands for it's the process that's
there to manage the CPU and memory
across your cluster so you might have a
bunch of different nodes you might say I
want to run a process with four gigs of
memory and two cores and Apache yarns
the process that figures out where it
should run that job and make sure that
you're not saturating the entire cluster
and it also ensures resources are being
shared across teams evenly so if you
have seventeen you want to make sure
that you're not monopolizing the cluster
and data engineering can't get their
work done
Petre arn is a common deployment
environment for lots of different data
science and engineering tools SPARC
flink
Hadoop hive and pollux that are all are
able to deploy on a yarn cluster so for
my day job at anaconda I work on a
similar tool called desk quick show of
hands how many people have used
heard of desk okay that's nice
so desk is another data science tool for
deploying Python across cluster many
people have asked if it would be
possible to deploy tasks on yarn more
generally it'd be nice to feel to deploy
any Python application on yarn a lot of
these things that run a new cluster are
Java processes they're blessed in some
form maybe ITR admin has sucked them up
in a way that they can run you but if
you're running like a general Python app
that you might have written you might
not be able to deploy it on your cluster
II of this hardware sitting there you're
not able to use it in that way so to
London read it works this took a lot of
work this was about all I did for the
last six months or so but at this point
we're able to do demos so right here I
have a notebook this is running on an
edge node and I had a little project
called desk yarn you import a yarn
cluster these are already run just to
speed things up you create a yarn
cluster object I'll talk about what this
all means later but in short we're
saying I want each worker to have two
cores and four gigs of memory it's got a
nice little rubber here I can scale up
the cluster connect to it
well that's doing and synchronously and
I can start doing work and all of this
is written in pure Python and that's
using the project that I'm talking about
today oh here I can even open up the
desk dashboard and you can see things
compute and just to prove that I'm not
lying
here is the application we're currently
looking at in the Hadoop scheduler so
it's running to ask can't even take a
look at the dashboard so back to the
science how did we get here so there are
lots of issues deploying Python on yarn
one does not simply do it a couple of
things yarn is written in Java and has
Java only tooling there is no client
library for any other language
supposedly it's back in language
protobufs Peck but it's not specified
and it's hard to write replicate other
language loop security is complicated
especially if you're using Kerberos
which is really the only way to secure
your cluster it's so complicated that
one of the main authors of ado wrote
this fun book that compares the Hadoop
and Kerberos to all of the Cthulhu
novels every chapter starts with things
about madness and staring into the void
Bob this room is a lot harder Java
centric programmers might use jars you
might package everything up into a jar
and distribute it around
Hadoop is meant written in this way it
expects this kind of an ecosystem Python
doesn't work that way we're used to be
able to pepper and kinda install stuff
and then not all clusters are the same
yarn configuration options are numerous
different things effects security in
different ways testing is hard it's also
it's hard to set up a Hydra cluster for
testing especially here trying to read
it on Travis so things weren't great but
things are better now I'm gonna be
talking about a couple of different
ecosystems projects that we've created
in the last year that should make going
about this process of deploying general
Python or really any language
applications on yds you can make better
use of your cluster so first project we
talked about is scan for those that
aren't knitters or crochet errs
scan is a unit of yarn it's a small
amount just enough for you to finish
your project that's what this project
skein tries to be we take the larger
yarn library and we try to simplify it
down in a way that it's more accessible
for you so this is the hello world looks
a lot like if you're familiar with
docker compose or other llamó based
respects skin is declarative so here
we're creating an app called a hello
world we're gonna display it in the
default queue accuse our yarn concept
trying to split up your cluster into
smaller bits of resources you might your
team might have a queue so this could be
easily data engineering or whatever your
team is named scan you declare a time a
number of different services you were
creating a service called hello we're
gonna allocate 128 megabytes to it and
one core and we're going
it just echo out hello world let's
actually run it there's a CLI we just
submit to the spec and it runs so I'm
going to do that right now I have that
whole file copied here locally I'm going
to save the output as a PI D let's see
cool so this is running I can check the
status of it I'm going to see it's
currently running I can go over to my
Hadoop dashboard and see oh and it's
just finished wonderful I can get the
logs and there you can see the command
echo hello world and it echoed out so
this was all done just as that as a user
you don't have to write any Java we've
done all of the hard parts for you going
back so what happened here this is a
simplified drawing of a yarn cluster you
might have an edge node or a number of
edge nodes you can SSH into this is
where if you were in this case when I
was showing the notebook that's where
the notebook is running the edge node is
where your client would run so first
when I submitted this application my
client asked the resource manager which
is running in a separate node to start
the application the resource manager
starts a special process called the
application master all processes or
applications that run on yarn have to
have an application master this is
usually a Java process it's exclusively
a Java process there's no other library
to do this the application master then
manages your app so it would say when
you want to start new containers it
would ask the resource manager to start
them the resource manager may give it a
container and they say no you're full we
can't give you anything else if your
application master gets a container it
can then start it up maybe on a
different note and then it just is in
charge of managing starting up and
stopping containers until the end of the
app so scan provides a generic
application master written in Java this
it reads the declarative spec that you
saw before and then it manages your
application as you go it's able to
dynamically scale so we saw before when
I was showing off a desk yard that you
can scale up and down at runtime I can
here I'm gonna kill a container and we
went from four workers to three you can
you can scale up
there's the slides all right scan
features so it has a declarative
language independent specification that
was the Amla file you saw before you
write you describe how your app should
look what resources you might need what
services you might want to spin up and
this game runs them for you it as a CLI
which is what I use to deploy that a
HelloWorld application it also has a
native Python API that should feel
hopefully intuitive we've done a lot of
work to make the commands hopefully feel
the spelling hopefully to make sense
it's written with G RPC which is an RPC
specification using protobuf so it's
easy to add other languages currently we
only have a native Python API but it'd
be easy enough to add one for NGO or our
whatever other language you might care
about the point as an application master
and a client provided these are the
processes that need to speak to the yarn
services these are the things that
currently have to be written in Java
because there's no other way to do it
we've wrapped those up as G RPC services
so they can talk to Python without you
having to worry about writing Java it
also has an internal key value store for
coordinating applications say you might
have some runtime configuration maybe a
service starts up and it needs to tell
what the other services its hosts nato's
you can store that there and then they
can pull that back out and it also has
an extensible web UI for tracking
interacting with applications and I'll
be showing these later all right a
little more useful script this is a
specifying how to run a Python script on
a node so instead of just echoing hello
world we're going to do a couple air
things in this case we're adding on
script I which is a script file I might
have some thing I want to run and maybe
it's alarm running
script I don't want to take up recesses
on the edge note I'd like to have that
run somewhere in their cluster where I
can shut down and log off and go home
for the day and then command Python
script I notice this doesn't distribute
any of the extra libraries you might
need so if you have all of the resources
you need in the Python distribution on
every node this would work fine but
often you don't maybe you need some
special library that IT hasn't installed
in every node in your cluster in that
case you need to distribute the files
with the application so for Java centric
programmers they wouldn't be using a
yarn
usually you would distribute things with
extra jars and then yarn would move
those around and get them located in the
nodes you could use them for python we
have a couple different libraries for
doing a similar thing one for called
Conda pack for if you're using Khan
environments and another called VM pack
if you're using virtual environments
this is let's see Conda pack is a CLI
command for packaging up a Kahn
environment into a archive file and then
yarn knows how to move around archive
files and it will automatically
unpackage them into a directory on the
all of the nodes that you're using so as
an example let's say I want to package
up I have an environment called high
script
I mean over right already about this
packaged up here so it's gonna collect
all the packages and it's gonna create
an archive file this takes a couple
seconds
wonderful so here we have so it's about
150 Meg's so it's a rather large thing
if you're using virtual m's these are
smaller but this is a way that you could
have an exact replica of your continent
on every node I'm gonna skip ahead real
quick
note this also works with PI spark so
this isn't specific to scan or anything
this is just a general yard feature in
our Docs we have Doc's on all of the
weird incantations you need to actually
make things work with PI spark or
sparkly R there's a lot of different
environment variables you need to set
but this is a way you can use Contin
environments with spark as well going
back one bit I have an example right
here that actually for the sake of time
I'm not gonna run this I'm just gonna
talk this one through here we'd have an
example Python script we ship a lot in
the environment packaged up as a tar
file the mapping here says to scan on
the other side on every note I want to
unzip or entire this archive file into a
folder called environment and then in my
actual list of commands I'm going to
source that environment and I can run my
script and this is gonna run inside the
same Khan environments that I would have
locally
'banahna node I can also set environment
variables here for those if you use
arrow which is a great library for
reading various different data sources
and converting between them sometimes
you have to specify where the HDFS
client lives so in this case that's what
I'm telling it with this environment
variable let's see moving on additional
features so I mentioned before we have a
key value store so instead of using
something like zookeeper or other things
that might be already running on your
cluster all skiing applications come
with a key value store bundled inside
the application master the process that
has to start before any other containers
start this is nice because you can have
a consistent environment you always know
that you have this key value store
available it's only accessible for
containers within that application and
you can store whatever dynamic
configuration you need there it's
inspired by at CD which is the key value
store used by Kirby 90s
we can mimic a lot of its operations
atomic transactions key and range
operations you can subscribe the keys I
can say I want to watch every key that
starts with desc
and as Keys come and go I'll get
notifications as they're set or deleted
and it has an ownership model to using
these various different operations you
can build larger concurrency
abstractions you can build distributed
queues locks various things on top of it
this was actually kind of fun to write
just because from a simple set of
primitives you can build complicated
concerning concurrency of scratch
abstractions I have another application
running right now I'm gonna demonstrate
this with so this is currently running I
can set a key I'll say foo and will set
its value to bar and then I can get that
key and so this is a way desk yarn in
which I showed before these scheduler
starts up first and then it stores its
address in the key value store and then
when all the workers start up they can
pull that address from the key value
store this is proved useful for other
applications too
one user is using a distributed queue to
manage the level of work throughout the
whole cluster and storing all of their
information in the key value store let's
see she also has an extensible web UI so
yarn supports application with you is if
you're deploying SPARC you've probably
seen the web UI if you click on the
resource manager you can go through and
see what sparks doing due to reasons it
only supports get operations you can't
use any modern web features like
WebSockets but you can still build some
useful dashboards going back to that
same dashboard application I currently
have running that is here let's pull
that up so this is the skein dashboard
I'm this application I have two services
one called dashboard and one called
sleeper it's got a number of different
containers running if some of these were
to die or
shut down they'd be in a completed
section I can take a look at the logs
for different services and run time and
then I mentioned that it's extensible
applications can register additional
pages here this one is running a voce
app which is being proxied out through
this can't use modern features like
WebSockets due to limitations in yarns
this is having to pull every couple
seconds to update new information but
this is all again written in pure Python
I didn't have to write any Java to do
this the actual code for this app is
like maybe a hundred lines alright so we
went through deploying on yarn we went
through packaging up dependencies one of
the other issues we mentioned was
testing so testing yarn applications is
rather tricky the yarn docks themselves
say if you don't test your yarn
applications in the secure I do cluster
it won't work it's there's a lot of
different things you need to make sure
you do you need to make sure you get
delegation tokens and make sure security
works with Kerberos and it's just a
whole handful of stuff cluster
deployment is also insider knowledge it
seems a lot of the configuration options
for urine are not well documented
knowing what is set in an enterprise
what Cloudera might set up or what
Hortonworks might actually set up is the
secret sauce and it's not trivial to set
one up on CI luckily we have a tool
called Hadoop test cluster for doing
this for you
it's just a CLI tool for spinning up
realistic test clusters these look like
production clusters it matches what
cloud era would do it supports all the
different kinds of authentication that
Hadoop supports runs fine locally or on
Travis we're using this for a couple
different projects to test Hadoop
integration on different Python projects
and it's designed to be extensible it is
PIP installable just pip install Hadoop
test cluster and then create a cluster
and login demonstrate that right now
I'll start or you can also mount local
directories so for testing
I might mount local scan directory and
then login and just to prove it
[Music]
interesting well that's a fun thing oh I
didn't type it right
cool so it creates there's a bunch of
different accounts already on here for
Kerberos things we create a key tab we
create a bunch of different things you
might want to use for automated testing
let's see so putting it all back
together all of these projects combined
have allowed us to write desk yarn which
I showed in the beginning and I'll talk
a little bit more about now
so desk yarn use this game to manage all
of its yarn things so the actual desk
errand library is maybe a hundred and
fifty lines of Python just wrapping
there's a skein specification and then
making some nice methods
it's installable like any other Python
library to use it on your cluster you
just pick ricotta install it onto your
edge node and you can get going
it doesn't require any admin or IT
permissions besides SSH access to the
edge node if you have access to that
edge node you can run tasks on your
cluster today you can create clusters
programmatically as we did here where we
created an object in this manages the
lifetime of your cluster or you can use
there's a CLI mirroring Sparx submit you
can submit applications to run in the
background on your cluster well you go
home and you know let it run overnight
[Music]
now we already showed that they're
ongoing in future work so one person
from Cote o which is an ad company in
France is using skåne to deploy
tensorflow on yarn they have a project
called TF yarn for running distributed
tensorflow on a yeren cluster ray is
another distributed python project
they're looking at using skein to deploy
a ray on yarn there is a project called
Jupiter enterprise gateway this is a
tool for instead of having Jupiter hub
which might run all of your kernels
locally this is a tool for spinning out
all of the kernels to run on any kind of
cluster maybe you have a crew Bernays
cluster and you want to run different
jupiter kernels on every node in this
case it would be nice to use skein to
deploy kernels on yarn and then also be
able to deploy tasks through Jupiter up
as well in a nice way and then there's
more work we want to do for task yarn
adaptive scheduling and then we'd like
to rewrite the dashboard to work in the
restrictions of the yard proxy which
doesn't support modern web features it's
currently a task dead dashboard uses
WebSockets surin review we have a couple
different projects that we talked about
skåne is a tool for scheduling and
managing yarn applications from pure
python you don't have to write an eight
the job it's already done
Conda pack and VM pack are tools for
packaging Python environments for
redistribution works well with anything
that deploys on yarn it also gives
useful of generally Hadoop test cluster
is a tool for nicely spinning up a test
cluster for testing on a realistic
Hadoop installation and then desk guard
uses all of these together to run tasks
on yarn clusters if you have if this
sounds useful to you I would love to
talk to you can get in contact via
Twitter or github or I'll be here the
rest of the conference and I believe we
have time for questions so the question
is can you use condom packet of Hadoop
yeah yeah plenty of people do that Conda
pack is designed to you have a kind of
environment it packages it up you can
move it somewhere else
unpackage it and then there's a small
little command to fix up anything that
didn't unpackage properly the first time
going a little more in-depth on what
that means is several mini packages
especially if you have a CLI commands
some kind of entry point embed absolute
paths into them so the simplest example
would be a shebang at a script file
Connor Peck rewrites those to work a
generally but for ones that can't be
absolute paths that might matter beyond
things that can be turned into relative
paths we write another tiny script
called Conda unpack and so the full
workflow would be entire your archive
run Conda unpack and it's exactly as if
Conda had installed everything there
originally so this is nice for
deployment scenarios where you have an
application ubongo it all up and then
you can deploy it just by untiring most
things though work without run
depict subscript anyone else
cool I'm sorry I didn't hear that
hello hi is it possible that we could
package all the dependencies like how
jar does from me when and builds it like
a individual thing for Python using
corner factly instead of taking the zip
and tearing it and all that like that's
that's exactly what Hana pack does is it
it archives your entire con environment
in a way that it can be reused and
activated on a node with the scripts
also that we develop for the modules
yeah okay thank you anyone else all
right well if you would like to talk to
me afterwards about any of these
projects or just about desk in general
I'll be around
thank you
[Applause]